ya hablé un montón de que es el sistema
de banca de reserva fraccionaria banca
de reserva fraccionaria hasta ahorita no
he hecho ningún comentario al respecto y
eso es justo lo que planeo hacer en este
vídeo así nada más como repaso de toda
la lista de reproducción de banca empecé
con un ejemplo bien sencillo en el cual
estamos en una isla supongamos que tú
tienes todo el oro de la isla y me lo
das a mí para que lo cuide entonces
ahora yo tengo este activo que se llama
oro lo voy a dibujar así oro y
supongamos que me diste 100 piezas
entonces me diste 100 piezas para cuidar
y también tengo un pasivo este es mi
banco primitivo de la isla y mi pasivo
es que este oro me lo puedes pedir así
cuando tú quieras este es mi pasivo si
dibujáramos tu hoja de balance este
sería tu activo entonces esto sería un
pagaré un pagaré para el depositante
para el depositante entonces yo te dije
pues mira este dinero lo voy a guardar
en mi bóveda pero en cualquier momento
que tú quieras puedes venir y retirarlo
de mi banco sin embargo sabemos por todo
lo que hemos visto de la reserva
fraccionaria que hay una pequeña
discrepancia entre lo que te dije lo que
te dije a ti el depositante y pues lo
que está pasando en verdad porque pues
la primera cosa que voy a hacer en
cuanto reciba tu depósito hay varias
opciones por ejemplo podría cobrar te
por guardar tu dinero sin embargo se me
ocurrió un esquema un poquito más más
rebuscado un esquema un poquito más
rebuscado digo eh y sabes que si a xavi
cómo te comportas y nunca sacas más de
diez piezas de oro a la vez entonces lo
que voy a hacer es prestar todo ese tu
diez de tus piezas de oro y acabamos en
esta situación diez piezas de oro
a ti te debo un pagaré de 100 piezas de
oro justo ahí pagaré de 100 piezas de
oro y las 90 piezas restantes se las
prestó a varios emprendedores de nuestra
isla a varios emprendedores
estos son préstamos a varios
emprendedores entonces está el préstamo
para a y el préstamo para ver esto está
súper padre porque yo obtengo interés
por estos préstamos que le hice a estos
cuates y suponiendo que estos cuates no
tiran el dinero a la basura pues yo voy
a obtener todo el dinero de regreso
entonces tú también yo gano un poco de
interés y te puedo decir hey mira estoy
guardando tu dinero gratis o obtuve un
poco de interés puedo hacer que la
bóveda se vea más bonita y todo mundo
está feliz suma muy bonito sin embargo
aquí hay una discrepancia que te dije a
ti que te dije a ti el depositante
lo que te dije es que puedes sacar 100
piezas de oro si empiezas de oro en
cualquier momento
puedes retirar 100 piezas de oro en
cualquier momento cualquier momento sin
embargo cuál es la realidad la realidad
la realidad es que solo puede sacar
solo puedes sacar 10 piezas de oro 10
piezas de oro a la vez y pues bueno no
sé si a esto le quieras llamar una
mentira pero segurito que esto de aquí
pues no es completamente verdadero ahora
muchos de ustedes me podrían decir pues
este es un ejemplo bien primitivo usando
piezas de oro pero seguro nuestro
sistema de banca actual no funciona así
lo que yo tengo que decir al respecto
para que veas que en nuestro sistema
actual no está tan lejos de esta
analogía es que el sistema que usamos
más bien trabaja de la siguiente manera
tienes 10 piezas de oro que me das
tienes 10 piezas de oro de halo pinto
por acá le escribo que este es el
sistema bancario moderno entonces lo que
tú haces es depositar 10 piezas de oro
más o menos así 10 piezas de oro
entonces yo te digo pues te debo 10
piezas de oro este de aquí es el pagaré
hasta ahorita todo se ve muy limpio pero
luego lo que voy a hacer es empezar a
abrir un montón de cuentas de cheques
claro el total de cuentas de cheques que
puedo abrir está limitado por un cierto
requisito de coeficiente de reserva pero
ahorita para que las matemáticas queden
fáciles vamos a ponerle que es de 10%
entonces lo que hago en el sistema
moderno es hacerle un préstamo a b le
hago un préstamo a ve ahí está su
préstamo y le doy a be una cuenta de
cheques le doy una cuenta y este es
equivalente a tu cuenta de cheques
entonces este es un pagaré para be para
b así que esta también es una promesa
para ver con esto le puedes decir mira
con tu cuenta de cheques puedes venir
pues no sé
digamos por este tanto que vas
40 digamos que estos 50 y esto
básicamente quiere decir que puede venir
en cualquier momento y retirar 40 piezas
de oro ahora sabemos que la realidad
pues la gente pues no va a y retiras y
oro de adeveras ya ni siquiera
trabajamos con oro verdad más bien sería
moneda de reservas pero es la misma idea
la gente tiene dinero que no
necesariamente está almacenado en las
reservas déjame hacerle otro préstamo a
la persona a otro préstamo a la persona
y para esto simplemente le tengo que
crear una cuenta de cheques
una cuenta o sea un pagaré para de 50 y
la única razón por la cual este sistema
funciona es que la gente utiliza estas
cuentas de cheques como moneda para
realizar pagos cuando yo te escribo un
cheque mira lo que está pasando cuando
escribo un cheque simplemente estoy
dando la orden para que se transfiera
algo de esta cuenta de cheques de aquí
la mía a la tuya y con esto así el oro
jamás tuvo que cambiar de manos así
funcionan las cosas pero si ves las dos
hojas de balance uno es el ejemplo
primitivo en mi isla donde yo tenía 100
piezas de oro y preste 90 pues todavía
debo 100 y le dije a las personas bueno
tal vez a sólo una mira puedes venir en
cualquier momento y obtener tus 100
piezas de vuelta sin embargo había
prestado todo excepto 10 a otras
personas
pero ahora viendo el sistema moderno
pues le dije a las personas que hay 100
piezas de oro y pues que pueden venir
por ella es verdad eran 10 para el
inicial 40 para este monito que le hice
un préstamo y otros 50 de este otro de
acá pero la realidad es que sólo tengo
10 piezas de oro en mi bóveda y mis
otros activos son simplemente préstamos
a las personas si ves
hojas de balance puedes notar que son
equivalentes a mí me gusta más empezar
con este porque creo que tiene más
sentido es el ejemplo que puedes usar
para explicarle a tu permito de 5 años
que es la reserva fraccionaria este de
acá parecería un poco más oscuro porque
estás creando préstamos y estás creando
algunos pagarés que parece que salen de
la nada pero al final ambos son iguales
igual de obscuros porque ambos tienen la
misma hoja de balance bar aquí es cuando
me preguntas oye sal y qué tiene de malo
todo esto bueno creo que es una pregunta
que le podríamos hacer hasta a mi gatos
claro si supiera hablar el problema es
que hay una diferencia entre lo que yo
le dije al depositante por ejemplo acá
le dije al depositante que podía retirar
si empiezas de oro cuando solo pueden
retirar 10 y acá le estoy diciendo al
depositante le estoy diciendo al
depositante que puede sacar su dinero
cuando sea sacar su dinero cuando sea
cuando sea pero en realidad en este
sistema moderno puedes retirar su dinero
cuando sea y voy a poner un asterisco
siempre y cuando siempre
y cuando no más del 10% de las personas
del 10% quieran pedir su dinero
al mismo tiempo quieran pedir su dinero
al mismo tiempo ahora obviamente esto o
sea cualquiera seguro está un poco
incómodo cuando dices esto pero le
puedes decir mira así es cuando funciona
nuestro sistema financiero esto es en lo
que está basado en lo que permite que
esté bonito este banco como quieras
llamarle esto permite que este banco sea
un intermediario entre los ahorradores
las personas que dan sus depósitos y los
inversionistas que van a hacer nuevos
proyectos y pues otras cosas más por
otro lado un contra argumento a esto de
alguien que está en contra de la reserva
fraccionaria el que para ser
intermediario no necesitas mentirle a
este monito mira vamos a hacerlo hacemos
exactamente este mismo escenario pero
ahora no le vamos a decir que puedes
sacar 100 piezas de oro si empiezas de
oro cuando quieras en vez de esto le
decimos que puede retirar hasta 10
piezas de oro en cada momento y que las
otras piezas de oro no se digamos estas
40 van a estar disponibles cuando
disponibles cuando no sé cuándo este
monito haya acabado de pagar sus deudas
en un año y las otras 50 piezas de oro
van a estar disponibles cuando este otro
cuate acabe de pagar su deuda no sé
digamos dentro de dos años entonces la
pregunta es por qué las cosas no suceden
así
bueno pues mira o sea si le dijeras al
depositante esto si le dijeras al
depositante que no puede obtener todo su
dinero en cualquier momento entonces
diría ok byte número uno asumiendo que
los préstamos se los hiciste a buenas
personas pues entonces quiero un poco
del interés que estás ganando por estos
préstamos porque finalmente es mi dinero
a ver si tú encerradas tu dinero por más
tiempo si no encerrar as este de aquí
está encerrado entonces la gente va a
querer interés por esto pero cuando el
banco dice esta media verdad entonces ya
no tienen que pagar tanto interés por
ese dinero porque la gente dice pues
mira puedo obtener mi dinero cuando yo
quiera
entonces ya no necesito tanto interés
pero la verdad es que no pueden obtener
todo a la vez únicamente pueden obtener
una fracción de su dinero al mismo
tiempo
entonces pasemos a otra idea en efecto
está haciendo insincero cuando le dices
al depositante que tiene su dinero en
cualquier momento justo por esta
infidelidad pues más o menos está
justificado que no les des tanto interés
como si su dinero estuviera encerrado
pero habrá algo malo con esto así
siempre y cuando tú seas un buen
inversionista y hagas un buen uso de
este dinero que no acaso todo el mundo
se beneficia con este sistema pues si
esto es cierto casi todo el tiempo
suponiendo lo que te acabo de decir pero
imaginemos una situación en la cual hay
múltiples bancos en este universo déjame
dibujar los múltiples bancos
este es el banco banco número uno por
acá tengo el banco número 2 y finalmente
el banco número 3 los bancos 1 y 2 son
muy honestos y muy buenos inversionistas
buenos inversionistas y sabemos que esto
no es tan fácil de decir no es tan fácil
de decir que banco es un buen
inversionista sobre todo en los buenos
tiempos porque en esos pues casi todos
los préstamos salen bien entonces son
buenos inversionistas pero al banco
número 3 le gusta tomar mucho riesgo
deja le escribo por aquí mucho riesgo
ahora porque se animaría a tomar mucho
riesgo pues ve supongamos que el banco
número 3 está dispuesto a prestarle a
gente que el banco 1 y el 2 no le iban a
prestar entonces en la hoja de balance
del banco 3 estos préstamos van a ser
préstamos más riesgosos porque haría
estos préstamos pues al prestarle a
gente más arriesgada entonces obtienes
más interés al tomar más riesgo eso
significa que van a obtener más interés
más interés
y cuando vean la situación de estos
bancos va a parecer que este es el que
genera más ganancias
genera más ganancia y peor tantito cómo
está ganando más interés entonces puede
compartir más desinterés con sus
depositantes y entonces puede ofrecer
cuentas de cheques con mayor interés
creo que le podemos decir así mayor
interés
depósitos
entonces en esta situación el banco que
se está arriesgando más va a generar más
ganancias por tanto va a poder ofrecer
más interés y entonces va a atraer más
clientes verdad por ejemplo para mí que
no sé mucho de bancos pues veo a estos
de aquí y todos me parecen muy similares
entonces pues voy a concluir que es
mejor darle el dinero a este banco de
acá pero qué sucede cuando las cosas
empiezan a salir mal tan pronto las
cosas empiezan a salir mal en el mundo
entonces este riesgo extra que se tomó
empieza a mostrar su lado feo y este
cuate se vuelve insolvente déjame ver si
puedo hacer su hoja de balance se vería
algo así hizo un montón de préstamos por
acá hay algo de reservas y además tiene
un montón de depósitos que pues tuvo yo
le pudimos haber dado todo esto de aquí
son pagarés a nuestro favor estos son
sus préstamos y tan pronto las cosas se
empiezan a poner feas estos préstamos
empiezan a salir mal y en cuanto uno de
ellos salga mal yo lo voy a escuchar en
las noticias
voy a salir corriendo voy a ir al banco
y le voy a decir oye sabes que dame mi
dinero así tan pronto como puedas
el primero entonces pues si me van a dar
mi dinero entonces yo prefiero todo el
dinero de mi cuenta de aquí me da mi
efectivo y con esto me acabo las
reservas luego cuando la siguiente
persona que digamos que es un poquito
más lenta que yo venga y le diga el
banco oye dame mi dinero el banco le va
a decir no hay dinero eso claro que va a
dejar este cuate enfurecido no obtuvo
sus reservas y por supuesto conforme
pasa el tiempo los activos de este banco
se hacen cada vez menos y menos valiosos
por los préstamos a malos inversionistas
y luego tienes más personas que se
enteran que él no pudo obtener su dinero
y por supuesto van a querer su dinero y
el banco va a ser insolvente de hecho no
sólo eso no va a tener liquidez y va a
ser insolvente ya había explicado antes
la diferencia pero con la falta de
liquidez puede ser que las deudas
todavía sean buenas creo que voy a
reiterar las cosas en este vídeo las
deudas pueden ser buenas pero que no
tenga el efectivo pero con la
insolvencia las deudas ya son malas y no
valen tanto como estos depósitos
entonces este banco arriesgado es
insolvente
insolvente ahora podrías decir pues
estos clientes se lo merecen estos
clientes se merecen lo que obtuvieron
porque pues fueron avariciosos e
invirtieron su dinero en estos bancos
oscuros sólo para obtener un poco más de
interés pero qué más pasa en esta
situación
mira por acá tenemos algunos bancos
buenos estos bancos hicieron préstamos
conservadores préstamos conservadores
entonces sus hojas de balances se verían
más o menos así tienen reservas por acá
tienen unos buenos préstamos así a
buenos emprendedores y por acá están sus
depósitos los depósitos pero en cuanto
este monito se entere de lo que pasó en
el banco de por acá va a decir las cosas
están pintando mal entonces pues nada
más para no arriesgarme voy a ir al
banco voy a sacar mi dinero y lo voy a
meter al colchón entonces él llega al
banco primero es el que corre más rápido
de todos los depositantes entonces él
pide su dinero el banco por supuesto que
se lo da sin embargo se acaba las
reservas
a todas las reservas pero él no era el
único este monito de acá también estaba
espantado de modo que también corre al
banco pide su dinero y el banco dice
chin qué crees ya sé que te hice una
promesa le hice la promesa de que podría
sacar todo tu dinero cuando quisieras
pero ese cuate que acaba de salir con
unos tenis se llevó todo lo que teníamos
en reservas creo que es un buen momento
para confesarte que te mentí en realidad
no tenía toda la disposición sino que
pues la verdad preste el resto de tu
dinero ahora no te preocupes yo soy un
buen banquero hice algunos préstamos
pero que son préstamos bien chidos
si me aguantas tantito te pago cuando me
paguen y él va estar así como
como que está muy mal que me hayas
mentido no y no es el único los otros
que corren más lento también van a venir
y van a pedir su dinero esto se le
conoce como un retiro masivo un retiro
masivo
el problema fue que tan sólo una manzana
una manzana podrida en el sistema generó
miedo e hizo que los clientes de todos
los bancos pidieran su dinero la cosa es
que como tenemos un sistema de reserva
fraccionaria el dinero no está ahí el
90% de ese dinero está prestado cuando
esto sucede en este banco luego va haber
un retiro masivo en el banco número 2 y
así se van a agotar los recursos de todo
el sistema bancario vámonos para acá en
esta situación de este lado en la cual
los activos todavía valen más o igual
que los pasivos entonces este banco
todavía está solvente pero no tiene
dinero para pagar estas cuentas
simplemente tiene un problema de
liquidez problema de liquidez en ese
momento no tiene las reservas justo por
eso tenemos un banco federal que es un
prestamista de último recurso este banco
puede ir a la reserva federal y decir
hey hay alguna gente que quiere su
dinero
hazme algunos préstamos el banco de la
reserva le va a prestar le va a prestar
un poco de dinero y claro ahora este
banco va a tener otro prestamista que se
llama el banco de la reserva federal
puedes usar este dinero para pagarle a
sus prestamistas pero esto deja otra
pregunta abierta como le hace el banco
de la reserva para diferenciar entre
este banco o sea puede decir va este
banco está bien déjame prestarle para
que no tenga problemas de liquidez pero
cómo le hace para distinguir entre este
banco y este banco de acá este banco
también va a ir a la reserva federal y
le va a decir en reserva estos préstamos
todavía están buenos pero necesito que
me prestes tantito para pagarle a la
gente ahorita y el banco va a decir pues
si te ves muy bien te ves como un
banquero limpio y decente que tiene un
reloj rolex en la muñeca vale te presto
y entonces va ahí le presta le presta y
entonces este banco también le debe a la
reserva federal bueno entonces a simple
vista podemos ver que en el sistema de
reserva fraccionaria tenemos dos
problemas uno tenemos un equilibrio
inestable un equilibrio inestable esto
es lo de que una manzana podrida puede
causar un retiro masivo por todas partes
un mal banco genera retiros masivos en
todo el sistema
todo el sistema después voy a platicar
un poco de cómo se las han ingeniado
para resolver este sistema que es un
seguro de bancos pero voy a hablar de
eso en el siguiente vídeo este es el
primer problema y luego el segundo
problema es que se vuelve muy difícil
distinguir entre los bancos buenos y los
bancos malos
difícil de distinguir o sea a lo mejor
al principio no es tan bueno si es algo
difícil es difícil pero se vuelve más
difícil cuando además tienes un banco de
la reserva que está dispuesto a hacer un
prestamista de último recurso después
vamos a ver que esto de seguro bancario
lo hace todavía más difícil y por qué lo
hace difícil porque este seguro incita a
los bancos a tomar más riesgo pues si
los tiempos son buenos pues los bancos
van a ganar más dinero pero cuando los
tiempos son malos es muy difícil que
todos los bancos sufran de la misma
manera va en el siguiente vídeo voy a
hablar de cómo se las ingeniaron para
resolver estos problemas y si tiene
sentido hacerlo así